à l'antenne de l'assise de
rivière-pilote la solidarité en action
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
locaux sont inondées combien de
centimètres de boue à l'intérieur je
dirais à peu près 30 à 40 cm même
peut-être un peu plus si on regarde les
placards 40 centimes vous avez perdu des
vêtements oui ah oui on en fait j'étais
beaucoup
alors comment vous allez vous remettre
de cette situation là alors déjà on se
remet bien puisqu'il ya la solidarité
qui est là il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous aident
et puis ma foi on n'a pas le choix on
nettoie et puis on verra on fera le
point après ce qu'on a perdu dans ce
salon de coiffure tout est sens dessus
dessous
il ne reste plus de traces de boue
depuis 6 heures il a fallu s'activer
j'ai trouvé ben hamad boulet les choses
toujours en place donc on a tous des
places et on a tout remis de façon à
pouvoir nettoyer donc voilà
même topo dans cette pâtisserie tout a
déjà été nettoyé
quand je suis arrivé c'était de la
mousse et s et d'inde et la soie voilà
vous avez eu de la boue jusqu'aux
communes centimètres de boue que vous
avez dix centimètres quand même dix
centimètres de boue et comme on est
quand même assez solide et un éventuel
mandat de la monuc qui interrompt alors
ce qui fait que j'ai eu des entrées de
sans problème et ça a été aussi rapide
le pire a quand même été évité à rivière
pilote seuls les rues wanaka hirai
france pannes ont été touchés la petite
rivière reste quand même sous
observation et les pilotins vigilant